um so okay nime is an open source data
analytics platform you can download it
from
www.nime.com you can play with it it's
graphic so and it has a bunch of
algorithms that you can use
for etl for everything okay so why i'm
saying that because it's open source so
every time that i go to customers since
i work as a consultant and i propose
them to use nime i always get two
questions if those are big companies
especially the first question is how
they pay our salaries
and but i'm not going to talk about that
today
and the second question is about support
you know they say what do we do about
support if something happens in the
middle of the night you know if i work
with another company i'm not going to
make names but if i work with another
company i call them and in theory i have
a contract and somebody has to answer so
what do i do with the open source staff
if the support is not coming
so and
this is what
what started this whole study so let's
see
yeah
okay so the first quest the first i
always hear two things that are the
people who are favorable to uh open
source they are somehow more positive
but there are the people especially uh
the big old-school companies they are
very especially the banks they are very
they don't trust the open source much
because you know it's uh they're not
sure if it's good enough the support is
another big issue
so usually what they say is you know you
get what you pay for so that's that's
one of the classic things that they say
um another thing that i've heard that
was on a linkedin discussion group uh
was that you know in which other
business do you get something for free
why should you get something for free in
the
programming business you know which
there's some reasons i mean you don't
get a car for free and you don't get
support for the car for free as well
and then this one was a a blogger and he
said you know he was working as a data
analytics consultant as well or he's
still working and he said you know if i
have a technical problem what do i do i
don't go around and i tell them do you
have time to solve my problem i mean
it's not going it doesn't work like that
in the business world
so why should i then go for open source
support
that's the other side of the medal
this is a tweet that i exchanged with
a few tweets that i exchanged with a
person i don't have a permission so i
blanked her name
and basically she was asking uh she's a
chemist and she was asking how to do
some chemistry things in lime i'm not a
chemist so i saw this tweet and i said
i'm sorry i cannot answer but you have
to ask the the name forum and probably
somebody is going to answer you and she
said well i just started with 9 and i'm
not a techie so i'm not going to
understand much of what is explained in
the in the 9 forum you know what and
then it's going to take too long i need
the answer immediately
so what do i do so anyway so we talked a
bit via twitter and uh and then i told
her okay so let's let's like that you
place your you post your question on the
night forum
if you get uh the answer
later than in one hour then i'm going to
offer you a beer the next time i'm in
london
and i saw then she did it and then every
10 minutes she was sending me a tweet
and she said nobody answered nobody
answered
no i have to fly to london and pay her
the beer
and so anyway but then at the end she
didn't say anything anymore so i assumed
somebody answered and uh you know and
that was a chemistry question i mean it
was not a techy question and obviously
obviously she was happy because she
didn't come back to me to ask for things
another example is that this is a person
who's actually working here in the um
i think menlo park and he's working also
as a data analytics consultant and i
started started learning nime so i asked
him if he needs help and he said no no
it's okay as long as i have google and
then i'm forum i can find all the
answers for all the questions i have
and then finally there is this one
percent rule that says that uh
you know there is the one percent of
people in the community who's active and
they are going to um
uh perform the supporting for you in the
community of the open source software
the the nice thing of the one percent is
that is it scales much better than in a
support team in a company where you pay
for
so now
the thing is is it good easy bad nime of
course was interested in knowing you
know how things were going because they
are open source so they need to somehow
show that they can do
support as well
so i we decided to start this project uh
as i said nam is an open data analytics
platform uh the best resource of the
open source software is the community so
we decided to start this project to
investigate uh how the ninth forum was
working
so from the beginning from scratch we
take the name forum we download
everything that is said in the nine
forum we used 2007 until 2012 because
the the the project was done at the end
of 2012
uh 2007 is when 9 started the forum
and we want to measure the quality of
the support that the forum offers okay
so that that was the goal
now um
the quality of the support can mean many
things so it means also in the the
number of answers that you need
so how competent the people
who answer are
how fast they are i mean if i get the
answer in 10 days
it's not useful what they talk about you
know are they going to get sidetracked
and then start a chatting line on a
completely different topic you know so
that means many things but first of all
we need to
uh get the data
so to get the data i could have asked
the nine people
and i could have said uh you know to
give me the data from their database but
then i thought you know i don't want to
have any filter uh in between what uh uh
you know what the real data is and what
they actually are storing because i
don't know if they clean it up
so i um i decided to use a web crawler
this is a snapshot of the nine forum uh
the nine forum is uh it has many
categories uh more or less 20 but there
are three categories that are very very
big uh so the name general the name
users and i don't remember the third one
so anyway and uh so you see here is the
first page uh when you access the name
forum and those are the categories um
that here those are the categories that
you can see
categories can spawn several pages
especially the the categories with a lot
of uh posts
you know there is the biggest one that
is the nime general this one spends 30
used to spend 32 pages probably now it's
more it's one year later
um
okay and each thread it's a normal form
so you have a
thread that consists of an initial post
and a number of comments for each post
okay so this is a an example of one of
the threads again again about chemistry
uh one of the some of the threads that
are on the nine forum
um
okay
so nine is a data analytics platform it
doesn't have a
a native node for web crawling so there
is not and i know that they developed
and they can you know inte you know use
it for web crawling
so you know what do you do the nice
thing of nime is that you can develop
your own stuff because it's open source
they have also a tool uh where you can
easily so it's a wizard where you can
easily develop some you know write a few
lines of java code and you can easily
develop a node so
it would be possible to do it yourself
but you know i work uh you know on a
limited time and they pay me for that
time so i don't want to waste time on
developing my own stuff
so what i did i went around in the
community
of nime and i found that there was a
group of students in um at the
university of dresden in germany and
they already developed a web crawler so
i imported their node and they were you
know warning me that maybe it was not
working it was the beta release and but
actually was working pretty well so
there were no main uh bugs
and um yeah so that's that's also the
first advantage of having a community
behind
the open source software that you know
if you need something that is not in the
software uh somebody has already
developed it for you before you
um after i downloaded the whole html
contents of the forum then i need the
parsing and for the parsing i use the
xml parser nodes and those are native of
nime you know you just
install them with the
core
part of the software
and this is the workflow
okay so now a few words for since none
by not many people no name so the
workflow
you can see is made of many nodes and
the gray nodes are meta nodes the meta
nodes are nodes that contain other nodes
and
so they're like i don't know the macro
for sas or the function for r
and um and so you you can see that each
one of the node has a
comment so i can't remember what they
are doing and each one of this section
can also be um annotated so that i can
remember what each section is doing
actually i made a video once and i i was
using powerpoint and then i thought why
should i use powerpoint and i was just
filming you know i used the annotation
to write the title and i was just
filming around
and it worked perfectly so without any
powerpoint slides
okay so
the first part here is where i
download the
the website so the html code uh this
part here is where i download the sub
sites so all the
the pages for each one of the categories
and this part here is where i uh parse
all the
threads in the in the categories so at
the end here i end up with a
data table which has one row for each
one of the post of or the comments of
the um
of the category of the whole the of the
old name forum
so if i if uh we want to go a bit more
in detail um here
this one is like it's a note that does
it's kind of an excel file so you can
write stuff in it so here i write the
the url that i want to crawl
and
the second node the second metanode is
the one that produces the list of the
sub urls to download of the suburl to
download so this is the
what this
web crawler here is doing
and this is the inside of the metanode
so i give the url to crawl as input
that's the node that i downloaded from
the community
and then i get this uh html code as
output
okay
the html code is saved in a special
special type cell type which is the xml
cell type so name has a few cell types
that are native and one of them is the
xml
there are a few also for the text mining
anyway
if you want to know you can ask me
so and one of them is the xml and that
fits very well with the
with the web crawler node
okay so then i move uh and i count all
the pages uh for each one of the
category
and here i get these these results
so here i get for example that the nime
general has 31 pages that i'm supposed
to download
i extract the list of the categories and
then i loop
around all of them to uh to fetch all
the threads for each category page
okay so this loop here those are loop
nodes this loop here
is the one that fetches all the threads
um
all the pages from the nime forum and
this part here is the one that performs
all the xml parsing uh from the
from the html content
okay
okay so this is the final result
at the end i have this data table i have
the url i have the the name of the
category in the forum the date the post
was posted the
author
uh the title of the post and the content
it's one row for each post or comment um
the ones here there are a few
rows without any uh title that's because
those are the comments to the same
thread here is the hd url of the thread
and here you have the
original post and then you have all the
comments that are related to this to
this thread
okay so this is the part about okay
this is the part about downloading the
data okay so now let's go with the
measurement uh first first of all i want
to know how active the community is so i
want to know if they write what uh you
know if they answer how many people
answer how much they write and all
so all those things that are related to
the ad to the activity of the community
uh to do that i use some basic
statistics so some counting some average
measures some so nothing nothing special
and like this is the workflow that i
used to calculate these uh statistics
here again i i have these two nodes they
extract the data that i've showed you
before
uh so here inside this this meta node
here actually there is a switch
the switch allows me to either retrieve
the data that i already
downloaded the last time or to refresh
my data with a new
download session okay and these meta
nodes are the ones that calculate uh for
example these two they calculate the
number of users by date and by year by
year
those are visualization node they uh
they plot in this case only the uh the
line plot uh of the data
and those are reporting nodes uh so i
eventually i packed i packaged
everything into a single report to send
them to the manager to the ceo of the
company
okay okay this one
so this is the content of this metanode
this is only um
accounting and then a moving average of
the time series and this is the plotting
the plot that comes from the
visualization node here
and those are the reporting node okay so
those are the results
first of all the the number of active
users as i said we start in 2007
february 2007 the form was created until
the end of 2012.
so you see the number of active users is
growing nicely an active user is an user
that has written at least once in the
forum i mean if he hasn't written during
that year then he's not considered for
the
for this
bar
for this year here
okay
okay so this one is is growing nicely
uh
but so the users are many they grow they
grew a lot um i wanted to show you
something so and there is a big jump
between 2010 and 2011.
um so do they they are many do they
write
so counting the number of posts they
also you know they also write i only
count the posts only the questions and
not the comments so those are those are
just the number of posts per year so
there is also a big jump here between
2010 and 2011. there was a a big um
shift in 2000 between 2010 and 2011 when
the company
started also a series of enterprise
products for uh you know collaborating
together
okay and this is the same uh bar chart
but uh with the higher resolutions of
per month instead of per year per month
and as you see here the jump uh between
the
um
you know the number of posts uh until
the end of 2010 and at the beginning of
2011 is pretty evident and i don't know
i like to say that
simon richard was one of the biggest
contributor of the
one of the biggest contributors of the
nine forum is that's when he joined
actually joined on february 2011 and
that's when the number of posts
increased
um okay so many users many posts does it
mean that that's a good support
uh so now i check the response time in
number of days
um so this is a
barrier again the average number of days
until i get the first comment okay
so one means it's the same day because i
started counting anyway from one one is
the same day uh so you see that uh most
of the years you need
i don't know maximum two days uh so
until tomorrow until you get an answer
so that's pretty comforting uh there was
a problem in 2010
that the the firm was under spam attacks
um very often and then they didn't get
an answer so that's why we have this
very high number uh between one
close to three uh for 2010. actually
some posts they never got an answer
okay so they answer fast but do are they
competent when they answer so do how
many comments do i need before i can
close the thread
um
so even in the in this in this graphic i
uh
i checked the number of comments here
and uh
the number of posts so how many posts
receive how many comments so a few posts
received zero comments and those are the
famous spam in 2010
um most of the com most of the posts
they receive only one comment so they
are happy with only one answer
some of the posts they need to answer i
have to say the people in the nine form
they're very polite so it's a lot of
thank you
please you know so it's they also count
as you know comment
um so anyway but there are very very few
um
post where i where uh actually men more
than three uh comments are needed more
than two or three comments are needed so
that means that
the forum is used is useful so there are
only a few questions that the community
cannot answer and for these questions
probably then they need to go to the
nime developers or uh to somebody else
okay and then finally i wanted to check
if
the
this community this forum was run by the
community or was run by uh the
nightmares you know if they pay people
to answer in the forum then of course uh
that's not very different from you know
having a it's not spontaneous it's not
very different from having a support
team that you pay
so i uh checked the the people who could
be related to nime and actually you
could see that the support uh provided
by nine becomes smaller uh as as soon as
the community takes over so in 2011 when
there was the big jump actually already
in 2010 well 2011 when there was the big
jump uh the community took over the
number of users grew and the community
took over with respect to the
nine employees
okay so uh okay so the forum is active
it's responsive it's competent
uh they give you a lot of answers so
nice
uh but what are they talking about i
mean what what what's the main
discussion there
okay so the the challenge now is to
classify topics and to detect and
possibly to the tech topic shifts so
let's see if we can learn something
about what uh the users of the forum are
talking about
uh you know if there is a showstopper
bag or something like that okay so in
this for this particular analysis we
only check the post we don't check the
com the comments so we want to know what
people ask okay if there is a recurring
problem so everybody's asking about
database then probably the database
notes are not working or something like
that
um
so we only focused on the post and not
on the answer
okay
the problem with class if we're doing a
text classification probably you know
that already but anyway my problem with
doing this kind of test classification
is that i don't have uh
classes already pre-built so people when
they talk i don't know you know they
write in a category so they all write in
name general because it's a general
question i don't know why
and so
you know what do they talk about it's a
i cannot say
before a priori i cannot say if they
talk about database or if they're going
to talk about reading input files or if
they're going to talk about looping
so you know this is not available
before so
i need some kind of a taxonomy to
perform the text mining classification
to perform the the document
classification
since they i don't have it from the
forum i've decided to borrow a taxonomy
from another
another place
nine so when you get a node when you
drag and drop the node from the node
repository into the um
workflow editor
you get uh there is a little information
that you get on the side and there is
the description of what the node does so
i thought
that you know if i use this
description as my training part so i
train my model on the description of the
9 notes and i mean more or less it's the
same topic because people are going to
ask about the notes and then i'm going
to use the model that i have trained on
the descriptions of the nine nodes i'm
going to apply it on what on the post
that people are uh
posting on the on the forum
i don't know
so
i i let's try and i will see i mean if
the two topics are completely different
then it's not going to work but if there
is a something then maybe it's not going
to be perfect but it's going to give me
an idea of what uh
you know of what some people at least
are going to talk about
so that's why i brought the misuse of
not description text to create the
training set
if i am able to classify what people are
talking about i am also able to see if
there is a topic shift so if people were
talking a lot about database at the
beginning is that is that because there
is a bug is that because they want new
features for databases
um does it go away so then people you
know if there is a bug the bug is
resolved they shouldn't talk about that
anymore otherwise there is another bug
or i don't know or maybe they want
something new so you know
it's interesting to know
if the topics of discussion
have changed
that's that was what i was talking about
so that's the nine platform
uh this is the area where you build your
workflow and this is the node repository
so you have the full list of nodes in
here and this is the description so if
you select one node
in this case it's selected here if you
select one node you get the description
of how the node works and what the task
that the node implements okay so this is
the kind of text i want to use for
to build my my model to train my model
on
okay and this is the workflow that i use
for the text mining
on the on the
upper part i get
so i get the node description texts from
the 9 description files and i and i
import them to use them as training set
here i build my model
and on the bottom part i import the data
from my
name forum okay
so
here i have the the data
that i extracted from the
nine description files and here i have
the data the text that i extracted from
the nine forum i train the model on the
description files i apply the model on
the nine forum texts is that clear
yeah
okay so and then at the end i have a bit
of post-processing on the classification
results
because what happens uh what happens
usually people don't talk about one
topic it's rare that somebody says
how you know the database unless it's a
bug
you know the the database is not working
the database connection is not working
or something like that then it's a
question about one specific topic but
usually people they ask about like
how do i loop on a list of files uh to
concatenate all the results in one uh
output table so in this case it would be
two topics is the uh reading the file
and it's the looping uh function so you
know it's always a more than one topic
uh when people ask you know ask for have
a question on the name forum so the
post-processing on the
results of the prediction
is because i took the first three
possible classes
and then i you know i define the three
um possible classes as the topic uh for
you know first class is the main topic
then there is a secondary topic and then
i used also a third third topic for the
text classification
and here again there is the reporting
because at the end i built a report that
i could send to the
ceo of the company
okay so i'll go step by step and let's
see uh i hope it's interesting
um so here i uh unzip the archive uh
with all the xml description files into
a temp location so this is the unzip
file node
and here
i get this kind of data so that's the
path for all the unzipped files
and here i get an that's an example of a
node description file and that's how the
node description is is done
okay
okay so and that's the um
at the end i loop around all the xml
files to read and pre-process the
contents and that that's the final
results so at the end i get the file
path the note category the nodes are
organized the name via node categories
the node name and the node description
okay and the node description is the
text that i use for my training
algorithm
um
i come here i use this meta node uh to
convert the description test text into a
document uh from which the stem the stem
terms are extracted
and
this is the how the
metanode looks like so in this case i
do the conversion i create the bag of
words i apply a number of filters i
erase punctuation i use the i apply the
portal stemmer to
you know to perform the stemming of the
words and then finally i use this key
graph uh keyword extractor um
this is because the post can the the
description can be very long and i only
want to focus on the keywords and i
don't want to you know to classify uh a
two big um
two high dimensional metrics uh also
because some of the words are
you know they are not necessary
so i used only a few uh keywords uh
extracted from the text
um
okay
so then at the end i uh use as target
for my training procedure i use the
the category to which the node is
belonging to which the node belongs
for example if i if i use the um the
text description the description text
for
the file reader node the target would be
dio because io is the category
in which the file reader node
is
okay so i
perform the same kind of pre-processing
also for the data coming from the
forum okay
and then i use a random forest
classifier to uh address the um the high
demand dimensionality of the problem and
this is the random forest classifier
as i said i did this uh kind of trick to
get some taxonomy because i didn't have
a taxonomy to apply to my
forum so i was not sure that if you know
the results would actually be correct so
this is the validation of the algorithm
on its own data to see if uh you know if
i have at least the hope that it's going
to work on an exogenous data set
if it's not even working on its own test
set on the test set that is extracted by
its data set and i have no hope that is
going to work on some data set
completely uh you know
not completely different but different
so
and uh
okay sorry and this was the result where
i got the accuracy of 80 percent so i
guess i can leave with an 80 accuracy
that maybe is going to deteriorate a bit
uh if i use a different data set
um
okay
so this is the data that i got from the
forum again
and this is again the uh the metrics
that i defined with the keyword
occurrence in the post text so i find
the keywords and then i use this
document
vector conversion to
translate
so for example the word follow is is
present or is not present in the
document so i use this uh
metrics to feed the random forest
classifier and uh
yeah and to train the model
okay finally this one i already uh said
i use a bit of post-processing to define
the three most likely classes that's
because usually people they put in the
same questions more than you know one
specific topic
okay so and this part is ranking which
one are the most like the three most
likely classes and that's the result um
so
i get see this is only one uh diagram
one
graphic i i get similar um
line plots also for the the second
detected topic and also for the third
detected topic so that's why i'm not
showing them so they're very similar to
this one
the data manipulation so the part the
etl nodes are always on top so that's
what people probably do the most when
they use data
they work on data manipulation uh you
know
for eighty percent of their workflows
the mining part
gets a lot of question and that's also a
big part of nimes so nime has uh uh the
is born uh with the nine with the mining
algorithm so the mining part with all
the classification algorithms and the
clustering algorithm and and so on is
the one that also gets a lot of posts so
etl and data mining
are the most uh talked about discussed
about uh posts
um and they they they stay like that
over the years as well so they started
like that in 2007 and they actually
increased much more in 2010 and 2011. so
that's an interesting one
um
there are two things that i would like
to to show the are
these notes here they're very low is the
r uh naim has a
so since that they they like to define
themselves as open so they they have a
few nodes to integrate r and to
integrate python perl and all other
scripts and r is of course the most
popular one so people sometimes they use
nime to do the etl or they mine the data
mining part because it's easier and then
they use art to refine it with some
exotic algorithms that nime doesn't have
yet
and those are the questions about r so
how to run their nodes uh how to the art
nodes are actually very nice because
it's an it's an editor for r and you
have the full
debugging environment uh you can inspect
the variables
you can
you have the syntax highlighting so you
know it's a it have to say for me at
least it's a big help when i program in
r
and um
so and you as you can see here there is
a very low number of questions for r and
i was very surprised and then i realized
that rs is its specific category uh you
know for the r nodes so this one is for
the um nine general category
um the time series is another thing that
nime didn't have uh last year there was
a node that was produced uh for
um
to change data to make possible the
training for time series uh and i don't
know it would be interesting to know to
analyze the data from for this year and
and to check if the time series got a
bit a boost in the in the question of
maybe nobody does time series analysis i
don't know
so something like that
okay so the last question is um
okay the last question is okay so um
there are a lot of users they talk a lot
uh we have this we have discovered what
they talk about
uh there was something about the
database i wanted to show you sorry uh
here for example if you check the
database here you can see that the
database had
a lot of questions at the beginning then
in 2011 somehow the whole discussions
about databases seem to be quiet and
then they started again in 2012.
and uh so we thought maybe there was you
know some bug at the beginning then it
stopped then it started again and then
we realized that the questions in 2012
are for the no no sql databases uh so
all the new questions that came can you
handle this kind of database can you
handle this kind of
query no sql query and so on okay
so the last topic
is i would like to to
identify who are the experts so in each
category
for example in the text processing
category are there going to be a few
experts that i can identify that's also
because you know they do a very nice
work for the for the time so you want to
pamper them a bit you want to you know
to reward them for what they're doing
um so you know it would be nice to
identify them and maybe to monitor what
they what they're saying
so this part
we
we selected each one of the category we
built um attack cloud for uh each one of
the category to see which which were the
words that were most common for that
partic particular forum category and
then we built a graph to see who was
talking to whom and if there were people
who were talking to everybody because
they were answering so we built some
network we did some network analytics
okay so again
we take all discussions in one forum
category and that's the output that we
want to have so we get all the
discussions in one form category for
example the web the name general is
probably
many many discussions but the text
processing is going to have a few
discussions and all very focused about
text mining
so
this one for example is about text
processing and you can see that the tech
cloud features the word document of
course
as the most important one but it also
features kilian kilian is the the
student
who originally developed the text mining
suit uh now he's not a student anymore
he used to be a student who originally
started the
text mining suit for nime
so everybody is of course referring to
him when talking about you know some
component of the text mining suit of
nine and this one here is the graph of
the people uh asking and answering in
the uh text processing um category as
you can see kilian is actually the
central part and is the the the one not
not the only one but
the most prominent person
who answers
everybody
in that particular category here there
is for example the richards 99 sorry
here and this is also another is a
chemist and i don't know he's everywhere
in the forum and obviously he's asking a
lot of questions about how to do text
processing yeah
so the blue ones are people who answer
the yellow one are people who ask
and the neutral ones i know i don't
remember
yeah
so this is how they are so the bigger
the size the more
exchange there is so for example this
killian richards 99 has a very thick
line so they've been talking a lot um
and yeah so that's uh
the distance i don't think as a as in
any meaning
and that's the the workflow that i used
to produce this
report so on the top you have a bit of a
statistic some statistics about who's
talking the most and
the top three contributors i think i
isolated the top top three contributors
of the that particular category in the
nine forum the part in the middle the
green one is the one that builds the
tech cloud and the the bottom part the
yellow part is the one that builds the
network graph to see who's talking to
whom
okay so i already said that
okay
um
so for the tag for the text analytics i
already said that i use the same
not the same but the
some of the same pre-processing that i
use for the previous text mining and
analysis i didn't use the
the taxonomy so the whole discussion
about taxonomy here is not
is not important because well i don't do
any classification i just produced the
tech cloud for a particular category uh
but anyway the pre-processing was a
similar one so i used i used the tagging
for example to take people who were
answering and people who were
asking
i used the
the dictionary tagger also to
define you know um
distinguished name from topics in the
tech cloud you remember kilian was red
and the document was green so there was
a bit of
tagging
involved to make the tech cloud a bit
more significant
um yeah and so this one was the result
uh at the end so as you see the
different colors they also refer to
different
uh
kind of entities so the person are red
uh the the
nine related terms are green and then
the verbs for example are
blue
okay
okay and this is about the network
analysis so i did the opposite the text
mining is the yellow part and the
network analytics is the green part
the network analysis ignores the topic
it only looks at the
relationships between users so among
users uh the network node represents
users and yeah
and the relationship between users
that's the input part of the
of the the network analytics
nodes
so that's the input table and you can
see you can have here the form category
those are nodes provided by some
third-party
development group
here is the author and here is the the
people who commented and how many times
they commented so that's the um
that's the data table that i created to
feed the network visualizer uh you know
for the report
okay and the network visualizer
visualizer is a
standard graph viewer and that's what it
shows this is for the cdk again the cdkn
is a chemistry
group they develop their own their own
nodes and so they have their own section
in the forum as well
and stefan is the main developer of the
cdk notes and as you see stefan is the
one who answers to everybody and has a
lot of exchanges
with i don't know who's the guy there
anyway with
all the other people
okay
and then eventually that's the reporting
that came out at the end is a multi-page
pdf output you click on the uh so on the
link and you get the page with the
description of that particular category
so here is the list of categories in the
forum you select one and then you get uh
yeah so it's a simple report just to
isolate the different categories because
the ceo was interested in some of the
categories and much less in some other
categories in the nine forum
and here are there are a few examples if
you want i can show you them
you know one after the other if you see
if you notice here so those are um
so this one was the text processing this
one is the artikte uh which is another
extension by a chemist chemistry
extension by a third-party
group and this one was the name general
right is that the name general
yeah
no it's the name users the name users is
one of these three big categories and as
you see there is not a dominant person
there are many people who answer and
many people who ask and
so you cannot isolate one single expert
like in the other
forum categories you can see a few for
example gabriel is thomas that's one of
the developers at nime
that's prominent but there are a few
more that are also as prominent and
yeah so
and that's
a bit more complex
graph okay
so that's a summary so i'm at the end
that's a summary um
what what i've done in this in this
workflow so in this series of workflow i
got data from a web crawler i extracted
some simple statistics i classified the
topics and i detected the topic shifts
to see you know if things changed in
time and interest and bugs and problems
changing time and
i use the network analytics to identify
users and also especially to identify
the experts
in each one of the category
so about open source support so at the
end the whole question was about open
source support so the nime user
community is healthy he's growing and
actually is a extremely important for
the
nime growing strategy
so probably
i don't know if nine was not open source
uh i don't think they could manage to
support all these people um on their own
and um the community developed
extensions are also a vital part of the
i'm experience uh so the the the http
retriever node the web crawler node i
actually got from the community it was
not part of the native sets of node of
nine and the one percent law of the
internet
culture seems to be
so realistic but only after you you have
passed a critical mass threshold so
before 2011
the involvement of the nine people was
pretty big it became smaller after the
2011 because the number of people grew
so the number of people in the community
grew
okay
if you want to download the examples
because yeah i don't know i was too fast
and you want to know more details and
something like that you can download it
from the nime website uh you can
download nine from the nine website and
then there is a in the menu there is uh
resources and then white papers and you
can download data workflows uh
everything from there and uh there is
also a little description of what has
been you know we have been doing um and
then you can of course you can also
email me if you need some more help
um now since uh we paid the lunch
there is a little uh advertisement that
is going to be at the computer history
museum on january 14th we are going to
have a
nime learning course a full day i think
it cost 150 basically to cover the cost
for the
renting of the
computer history museum and so yeah so
if you want to be there you can find the
group on meetup
as well and if you want to there is this
book that a fantastic person brought and
so if you want you can get a free copy
by using this meetup sf-13 code so if
anybody's interested
that's it
i'm finished
you